shots ring out as mourners bury
palestinian bilal
the flags of palestinian factions
including fatah and hamas wave in a
moment of unity
bilal was killed by the israeli army
late in a raid on wednesday as it
demolished the home of diya hamarshi and
eleven members of his family diehamarcia
was accused of killing five israelis in
tel aviv in march before being killed by
israeli police
ambulance medic is batawi says the raid
was more intense than any he's
previously experienced
the israeli army raided the town around
9 pm it was barbaric the first minutes
of the raid we dealt with injuries to
three individuals gunshot wounds to the
stomach the jaw and the neck their
survivors are in critical condition and
are still being treated
the raid took place here at what was the
hamashar family home
dear's uncle ayman hamisha has returned
to what's left
now although dear was killed during his
attack on israelis in march his family
have also been punished by their home
being made uninhabitable and their
belongings destroyed
a form of collective punishment this has
long been a policy for israel
since 1967 hundreds of houses have been
demolished in this way according to
israeli human rights organizations no
evidence has been given that the hamisha
family were involved or even knew of
diaz plans
of course he didn't tell us the israelis
have purpose they have already
demolished homes are all the owners
guilty
99 have nothing to do with it while they
say this is the house of a terrorist the
reasons are deeper they want to weaken
you demolish you depress you
there's no way the family will ever be
allowed to live in this house again if
they try and rebuild the israelis will
come back and destroy it that's 11
members of the household that are now
homeless 11 members that didn't know
what plans that dia hamershay had 11
members of the family who have simply
been punished for living under the same
roof imran khan al jazeera southwest of
janine